hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage the show we sit down
with your favorite comedians if
they go classy after there's the big old
piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day here down in the
basement
aunt toddy's joint she's upstairs taking
a nap so for god's sakes keep
it damn take your shoes off will ya
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's my old pal
my good pal we got a funny episode
planned we're gonna have a great time
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey what's up everybody happy
to be here thanks so much for tuning in
as always a little bit of business
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
subscribe there please
also t-shirts and hoodies at
podcastmore.com
get on it go there while supplies list
also go to [ __ ] patreon.com
ru garbage to get bonus content you get
videos you get
live streams you get all that kind of
stuff dude so [ __ ] help us pay the
bills
keep the lights on i got the landlord
breathing down my back
we got our first live stream coming up
pretty soon right yeah still got to
schedule it
it's going to be good going to be good
times like i said i'm going all butthole
okay i'm doing hey let's take a minute
let's tip our caps to our old pal
our producer extraordinaire the [ __ ]
magic man the chicago kid
running by the name of t-bone these days
on the circuit t-bone
t-bone give it up for toby mcmullen
everybody i i hate the t-bone that's why
it's sticking baby i didn't like kippy
five years later
my nephews call me uncle kippy
gang today is what we all really really
enjoy
it's the holidays it's a time for
another family
episode here on the podcast we have an
old pal
here with us today and he's got a weird
energy i gotta tell you
it's not the guy you want coming over
he's the uncle's friend that shows up
for thanksgiving this guy
his name's jerry sits in the corner hi
shrug right now buddy [ __ ] take your
breath your face is red
he needs a cup of decaf and a hot meal
i'll tell you that correct gum
he's episode number one el numero uno
our old pal gonna sit in with us while
we do a little bit of fan
questions it's a family episode we got
the cookies out on the table
cause we got a little company give it up
for ian finance everybody hello
i'm just kidding chomping at the bits to
[ __ ] talk pull it off his
corduroy jack that power long entrance
he's getting really long-winded in the
intro and tony's upstairs
making a baccarate cheese and she went
to the store earlier there's no auntie
she ended up getting some jello
and then she forgot to get the basket
roberts
there really is an aunt toddy it's brian
six's aunt it's a
hoodie i had an ant and cookie i'm sure
you did
yeah what was her what was her what was
her poison
what did she like oh my god she was on
something she looked like
she looked like elizabeth taylor and
people would ask her for her autograph
did you design a cookie
i'm cookie don't you forget it yeah
her name was cookie or what i think it
was cookie she's been it was it for
a long time i mean it wasn't cookie no
her name was carmella and baby
and carmella yeah and carmilla i famous
carmella is a hard name i'll tell you
that you had a rough paper out of your
carmelo yeah
i had another aunt carmella but i called
her aunt pesti
she was an exterminator she was always
bothering me she was grabbing yourself
she was grabbing my face stroking me
give me that little boy keep your hands
up why do you think i'm so high
strung i was thinking
i started putting duct tape around my
underwear
i couldn't keep this brought out of the
goods you know what i mean
oh i started wearing suspenders at a
young age
i did wear suspenders oh very good i
loved it
man you
you're like a little kid that wears a
suit i can see that
every picture they have worse every
picture today i was the best looking kid
on the block
you probably always talked in rhymes and
riddles and stuff oh my god yeah
totally yeah yeah wanted to be a
magician for a little while i had a
cousin who was a magician
he was the ronald mcdonald what was his
name uh brian reboyne
i didn't mean in real life
i think he's here we used to get we used
to get a birthday clown for me that i
was in love with named bingo and he was
from newport delaware and needed an
accent
it came back my birthday no makeup
watch me make this jack daniels
disappear we have my birthday at the
ground round
comedy we go did you know that ian was
strong
he inflects your muscles the fact that
you would have a birthday party at
ground round
is 100 trash who are you talking and
then you would have a magician come to
the restaurant yes
i don't know in this coat
thumb in your ass magic drink in front
of your parents
here's a trick i'm gonna touch you
little boy dick and your parents aren't
gonna know
all right thanks bingo i'm gonna make
your innocence disappear
you guys know how to create a lawsuit
let me show you
this trick lasts years it's called
latent memories
you'll be watching a movie and one day
you'll cry
oh my god
holy [ __ ] we gotta slow down this is too
crazy
bingo the clown yeah i grew up uh shout
out to
uh paul conover growing up his mom was
giggles of the clown
and it's tough when your mom oh giggles
and she would do like
we had the holland hoopty do was like
the the prayers what
it was like the [ __ ] the fair in
elementary school i'm driving my mom
blowing dude to the gas station
birthday clown oh my god it was she
would show up and then like he hated it
he was a he used to eat paper shout out
to pete unit
dude he was like a ghost no problem here
you could give him a composition book
and he would [ __ ] finish it by gym
class
wow got some mustard that's [ __ ]
seated repression right there
you look over he's just eating a paper
cup like it's nothing jesus
cup of coffee that's where his mom kept
the makeup
the paper cup trying to eat it away yeah
that was
dude being if your dad was a client i
saw anything that's a tough thing to
come back from
especially in a small town if he doesn't
end another market it's one thing but if
he's doing it home grown yeah if you're
going out to royersford
you live in manning yeah showing up for
church in the big shoes
you still got some makeup on your face
the night before
sorry i didn't have time i didn't have
time
you're crying at church you pull out a
handkerchief that doesn't stop existing
yeah speaking of miracles huh let me do
a little time here
ian buddy thank you so much for coming
in thank you
thank you so much my head hurts already
we've been laughing for seven minutes
straight
oh i gotta find some bingo videos what
was the latest you got him
at a party 17
no no i i don't know two or three years
and they disappeared
then we heard some bingo stories years
later kind of made sense
bingo was doing it yeah yeah yeah
upstate
yeah for touching kids over the same age
pulling other things
my god did you just know that ian was
strong
that's the way he talked no wonder
weird now we got a hat here reaching the
hat yeah
yeah reach deep i never [ __ ] with clowns
growing up
and i didn't want anybody showing up to
my party like that my mom never got
magicians clowns none of that nah
were you more like a snake guy
more of a jeep party kind of guy you
know i here's the ears it's
foley's fifth birthday here's some
snakes it's a [ __ ] daytime talk show
you never had the snake friend well
their name was always like jake or colin
i had and they always said no they had
like a snake handler come to their
birthday party the only thing we ever
maybe a [ __ ] bouncy castle or
something like that oh my gosh no dudes
were showing up
like [ __ ] wild bill or anything like
that some presentation
i think i said it in a bonus episode i
had the [ __ ] union rat the protest
rat
because my family's such blue-collar
[ __ ] mooks that
had my first holy communion [ __ ]
shout out to jimmy he was there
uncle jimmy he's not my own stuck a pole
in it said it was a unicorn is it a
jewish relative
no [ __ ] jimmy was like yeah i forgot
damn i got i got this suit in a car
and he went out and dressed up and put
the rat suit on it came and all the kids
are like oh i thought you meant the big
blow up
yeah i thought they got that to like
protest your communion
yeah we didn't have the right
tournaments this kid's a scab yeah yeah
he got the body of christ before the
first holy communion
i paid my money six instead of seven you
[ __ ] i didn't know that i didn't know
he had dressed
up no he would be the guy like they
obviously had to blow up rap but he
would be the guy who would dress up and
the word was he would dress up in the
rat and then like go smash windows of
non-union projects or whatever
what uh that's yeah what's what the
[ __ ] union guys do yeah
go sit over there yeah go talk to some
union guys yeah they don't
yeah they're all lazy now i don't they
no you hear that locals will have it
yeah it doesn't take much [ __ ] work
to not go to work huh
ian huff over the the guys that get the
big
blow up rats also in their spare time
smash windows
no but like a lot of times something
doesn't go this was back in the day but
if something didn't go non-union if
something went non-union over union wow
they would like you know just and they'd
be like oh the front windows of this
hotel are done and then you come into
the job site in the morning they'd be
[ __ ]
you were a non-union carpenter for a
little while i was yeah and then my
first [ __ ] comedy my first
construction job i was a unskilled
laborer
and now shut the [ __ ] up
we were making uh we were making state
rate which was like insane we're making
like 27.50 an hour it's [ __ ] crazy
but i i didn't go to work one day and i
lied to my mom and i was like oh there's
an issue with the union the electrical
the electricians union didn't show up
and we couldn't turn on any lights
because you're not supposed to
do any of their work at all like uh
plumbers
would like leave their [ __ ] out and we
weren't allowed to clean it up the
the plumber's union a union worker had
to clean up the plumber's work you know
what i mean
so like that would delay work whatever
shout out to local so so i told my mom i
was like yeah there's an issue with the
electricians union they uh they didn't
show up so we couldn't turn the lights
on we couldn't use any of the power
sorry
i didn't have work today and then a
buddy called
and my mom was like oh it's a shame what
are you doing with your off day not
being at work he's like what are you
talking about my mom was like
didn't the electricians not turn on the
power no
i was wondering where ian was i was like
you [ __ ] rat bastard
kippy got one of your guys to smash the
window
piece of [ __ ] jimmy it wasn't as good as
the bingo story but i'll give it to you
that way
yeah you know all right t-bone cut it
let's put some lipstick on that pig yeah
he's a [ __ ] buzzsaw tv let's get into
some [ __ ] patreon questions
yeah let's do it a patreon we love all
you guys thank you for sending in
questions
these are my favorites i love the family
episode and i'm so glad you're here yeah
this is great being the first guest
um welcome back to the new studio thank
you i love the new studio i guess you
can call the patreon episode today the
patreon
oh all right and he just he just dropped
a hundred dollar mic that's coming up
it's coming out of here that's coming
out of your bottom line i'm getting
bigger small business owners here
um no guys so listen uh we get thousands
of [ __ ] at this point thousands of uh
questions suggestions to ask our guests
and stuff to be used to play the game
um and part of what we do to you know
give you an incentive to join the
patreon once you join the patreon we
will ask one of your garbage questions
when you join um and we have you know so
many to get through so we wanted to
bring ian
come sit down answer some of the
questions with us nice little family
episode that's right
just in time for the holiday this is uh
this isn't even a question this is more
of a
you know uh this is from jeff sharma
shout out to jeff thanks jeff
i i don't know what i think ian was all
about this it just says liverwurst
garbage or class
what are you a liverwurst guy never had
it really never
wow never happened i would have pegged
you for a big lw
like elementary school never had it
remember
remember there was an episode of doug
where he had to eat liverwurst and
onions
no yeah oh grossed me out that was a
great show yep
um shout out doug shout out to yep you
were probably
and still are a big liverwurst guy shout
out the neighbor mr binks what was his
name
the blue guy i don't know about duck
funny i grew up with a guy that looked
like roger klotz and we called him roger
he had like the [ __ ] face shaped like
his oh god
that poor fella shout out to frank i
didn't watch doug
yeah you were [ __ ] yeah you were like
grad school
grad school yeah for percocet addiction
he was following oar around the world
it was a crazy game of poker
i'm 35.
why were they a percocet man no but
you're a percocet
and that's the riff we're in right now
okay
come on [ __ ] it all right depositions
does that really have to be real
[ __ ] shooting from the hip and you're
like oh danger
john mayer of pill town
kid's coming in hot look out union
non-union i don't care
hire this man somebody get me bingo on
the phone
bingo holy [ __ ]
liverwurst no really
however yeah it's chicken livers what
mixed up whatever that's called chicken
patent damage
chicken lips it's not chicken pate uh
what's it called
[ __ ] disgusting yeah yeah chicken
livers when you when you mash them up
and they're like mixed with like some
[ __ ] they're really good on crackers
and i love pate i love goose liver pate
and all that stuff
i like grief i do not like you yeah i
like to tartare
like a tuna
can i speak to your manager can i get a
raw bag of velveeta
oh my god uh my my step that big was a
liver where he became a little worse guy
and like you're talking in the water
i don't know what it's me no that smell
you can smell from the name
you gotta rip it out that's the cookie
that's the little dough guy
oh no pillsbury yeah that's not amazing
what what are you talking about there's
your meat cookies
it comes in like a sausage
yeah it's like rat it's compressed and
right yeah that stuff's that's what you
give dogs
dude that [ __ ] my my stepdad used to
bring it home and it would ruin all the
rest of the lunch meat because it would
bleed into the other
one dude i remember at one point ago mom
i'm sitting there trying to have a
[ __ ] turkey and cheese sammy
and it tastes like i'm eating a shoe
we made him keep it in the garage at one
point i paired it in the backyard
dog was going crazy wait you kept your
uncle's food
in your house
that liverwurst i left here i don't want
the kids eating it don't touch it i'm
holding it for a friend
yeah hey i'm late on my rent for that
corner in the fridge
can you give me until friday hey listen
if you don't have money i'm gonna move
you to the garage bridge okay
this is this is real estate
location location location
liverworts in there pretending like it's
not home he's not here
i haven't seen him just those baloneys
listen i can't pay alimony you gotta be
real
[ __ ] tight with that [ __ ] especially
when you've got kids in the house
you got a vacuum yeah you can't you
can't have [ __ ] adult foods
mixing in with [ __ ] snacks and [ __ ]
like that in the fridge
[ __ ] i i've had pudding that tasted like
onions before
why [ __ ] that yeah oh you ever you ever
go to drink a sprite in its vodka
you ever do that what when your mom's
hiding drinks
i thought you're going to say crystal
lightning or something like that i don't
know if you open the ryan household but
we do not hide our alcohol
it is out there in the open the only
time there's a
couple a couple of people in the family
will do uh what they call afternoon
coffees
and it's a drink in a wawa cup
and who knows what they're doing but it
ain't legal i know that much
i never really had meats bleeding into
other snacks in my household
yeah inside the straw the lunch meat
cabinet that liverwurst any of that
stuff yeah so we used to have to keep it
i
won't buy goldmine it sounds like dog
food yeah you got friends coming over
after like a you know after a soccer
game they're looking for orange yeah
everything
is full of ham and a mouthful of meat
fistfully good game today baby
gravy
jesus christ
yeah no on the liverwurst buddy no thank
you no
oh [ __ ] i like the olive oil ryan tell
you that
olive loaf yeah it's bologna with the
olives in it
you know what i'm talking about yeah oh
i'm trying to church it up
and you're not doing it have you ever
had vietnamese deli cuts
woof no what are they there's a [ __ ] no
no no no
i i was really in the mood for like
italian deli meats i went to a
vietnamese sandwich shop and they had
like
naturally vietnamese meats i was like oh
let me try these and it was the grossest
[ __ ] i've ever tasted
it looked like that olive loaf or
whatever
you know something right yeah it was
just like ears of soldiers
mine needs a haircut
what i was gonna say is some of those
vietnamese sandwiches
have have awesome have like ham and they
they put pate
on on sandwiches sometimes it's really
good i could see vietnamese
no but there's just some stuff i won't
like i've tried
i'll try anything like i've tried rabbit
rabbit heart
whatever i do not like it you know
i've tried pate not for me is this a big
ghost
it's a big o's trunks what the [ __ ] is
that man
it's a heart of rabbits i'm aware of
what it is but where are you having that
i had it in uh malta the country
yeah that's not bad oh you travel oh
yeah
okay i remember now um
that seemed shady yeah what was that i
thought i didn't think you were
traveling
i i thought you meant like traveling
like you were decompressing at a
facility in malta
um oh henry's grad school
all right we got another one here what
do you got this is
uh these are the best this is this is
from robert
uh mccray have you ever referred to the
remote control
as a clicker or remote control
no also i mean what do you what did you
call it growing it was a clicker
clicker get the clicker that's trash oh
yeah you're just naming it after the
sound that it makes
that's so [ __ ] good yeah there's a
proper name to it
you call it the clicker and you call
your mom the yeller
you call your dad the lever
it's i was it was a remote where's the
in our house
look at you it's still a duct tape on
the back big shot
scotch tape yeah we did it for a while
that's great
yeah i remember you had to get up and
turn it like we didn't have the remote
or the universe
oh yeah just went with it for a little
while remember when tv didn't exist from
like midnight to 6 a.m
and you've got up at like 5 55 to watch
saturday morning cartoons yeah
like the rainbow colors still be on uh
what was it that guy's name
the captain kangaroo captain kangaroo
yes
all right come on in the morning i feel
like that was really old though what
year was that
uh i don't know like eighties when we
find out that ian's
four years
i'm surprised you remember doug and
captain kangaroo yeah
i got a lot of memories oh my god
you were probably some i wish i could
click away you were probably playing in
front of that tv from morning to night
keep you had every aunt cookie's hair
and tiny tiny little like quill in his
mouth
[ __ ] keep him on ah keep him from
bringing that's how it's funny
um all right this is this is from uh
this is a hot up baby we are running and
gunning
this is uh let's see this is from the
one zero two eight nine
real original is it trashy to gas up
your car in a quarter tank half tank at
a time
you have a car you have a car right i
did you did i did what did you do
did you guys ever charge your friends
for gas that's true you've charged me
for gas again
there you go just give me like 425 yeah
no well listen i put 50 there was it was
at least a quarter tank in there when i
picked you up
guys you see five dollars yes you filled
up only a quarter at a time well i
i still i'm still weird with it i don't
like i don't know i'm always
even when it's really low i'm like just
i never say fill it up like give me 30.
real 20 or 30. that's true yeah i'll
give a 20
and just fill it up for that yeah
whatever this get this will get me to
where i'm going and back
plus i think it's because i was so poor
and still poor but poor for a long time
then i'm like this is i can't have
operating capital tied up in the get
tied up in the game operating capital
what the [ __ ] is this
i'll put 10 bucks in i'm not going to
fill it up with 30 i might need that 20.
i'm gonna get a pack of bernies or
something you know what i mean yeah but
then
five will get me to where i'm going
halfway to your blaze you run out of gas
when you're young
yes obviously or 34. now i got
the cards in [ __ ] and i juice it all the
way up every time let me tell you
something
it's a really good feeling to coming out
of the [ __ ]
car wash and gassing up the car putting
the new [ __ ] little tree air
freshener
having a full tank you get ham flavors
he puts it around his neck everything in
a cured meat
uh which i used to be a volunteer
firefighter and they would never let it
get past a half tank
they'd always fill it up
what do you guys say we just gotta let
the house burn down we forgot to gas it
up
can you imagine that how trash he's at
the fire oh my god the gas in there
they're going to get the little truck to
bring him gasoline
i think i saw texaco about a mile back
can we stretch the hose uh i try not to
let it go under
half the tank and i fill it up all the
time because i know it's better for the
car but i understand
i let mine get low oh i like to see
where the light goes oh yeah i'll get i
mean because
i have the the digital where it tells
you like [ __ ] you know you got 20
miles left or whatever and the light
comes oh that thing's dangerous
i know because you're pulling push yeah
i got it it comes on at 20 seconds and
it switches on you real quick
well once i get 120 once it's five
pencils once you get below 10
it gets dicey it's a really they're
really guessing it's a maybe yeah it
really is
well before that you just had to see the
light and be like i think
i think i got 20 like 20 miles i always
like oh they say 20 miles
the anxiety they just way more like
that's how anxious
i think we are as as people it's the
anxiety just from that
you know what i mean it's like when it's
on i know thanks bigger point
well really as a human we all need to
come together in our tanks with love
trying to add to the conversation yeah
have you ever ran out of gas uh
no no i don't think it's surprising
yeah no i haven't i have but that's the
pull for people that need money they
have a guest hey i just need
10 bucks in my gas can i please blah
blah blah
you know that's that's the hook at every
gas station in delaware now you're
always that's for a grip don't you i
like it
how do you think i got it no that that's
what they do in in delaware people are
coming hey can i just get money for gas
and you give it to them you're like wow
you really turned that gas into heroin
you really turned your car into a needle
that's
where i ran out of gas i had to walk to
the gas station buy the little red thing
yeah fill it up walk back get the car
and then drive back to the gas station
to [ __ ] fill up
fill up the coin yeah have you ever had
a siphon gas before
no i've had to help a friend with that
yeah my stepdad did it
yeah oh that's divi that was for
mechanical things around your house
where did you do it no
did the person who you were siphoning
the gas out of their car know you were
siphoning gas out of there
no no they knew they knew yeah yeah yeah
if you have a lot in the tank you you
got a little spare oh that's something
that's a brutal you take some out of the
tank if you wanted you cropping the 20s
well the gas lines were so long i had a
date with a flapper i had to get to it
my license plate in need of a number it
wasn't my gas steering i was saving an
alcohol because it was illegal at the
time
jesus christ that's awesome delaware
who dude delaware what delaware is now
they're level off
trash it's like country
hick city part of delaware is below the
mason dixon line
the cities one time one time there was
like a
dale earnhardt flag on someone's [ __ ]
lawn and we rolled by and to like heckle
them
they were on their front lawn sitting in
lawn chairs they're like jeff gordon
sucks thinking that like they'd be like
hey [ __ ] you it's like
yeah he's a [ __ ] yeah well i grew up in
a i was in earnhardt house
and you hated jeff gordon because dale
earnhardt was like the old [ __ ]
cowboy yes and for this pretty boy
gordon came in yes
and you were like what the [ __ ] so if
you were an earnhardt fan you hated
right
right what was earnhardt's favorite pink
floyd album
uh the wall
crashing into the wall died yeah we're
gonna cut that so my stepdad doesn't
hear it
shout out to the intimidator he had a
huge dude he had a
shot and he had like a 40-foot banner
the intimidator
he went out so trash that was assault it
was you always say that what are you
commissioning a wall in a nascar event i
know pretty hard
yeah but they typically you're gonna go
on the [ __ ] yeah right and blow a
gasket
um all right this is we talked about
this briefly at the beginning and i
couldn't find the question
excellent this is uh from gno gianolim2
were you ever fired from a job for
committing too many no calls no shows or
did you ever just like never
show up wow i never did i never did a no
call no show
what never ever ever no really but i did
jobs i
did quit a job after two days oh yeah
it was a packaging job down state
down state
but we noticed within the the second day
that
if you broke a package you had to go
right up a slip and you could go into
the air-conditioned office and do it so
we kept breaking packages
and then afterwards i started on i
started on a wednesday and then i i quit
like that monday you just you were did
you tell them hey i quit
yeah yeah i went this far once this is
back in my uh
certain days when i was partaking
certain things we call them your skinny
days
yeah we know how well foley's doing by
how fat he is
somebody somebody on the youtube
comments and i think fully puts on 20
pounds an episode oh my god and i can't
i can't and with your help on patreon it
could be 30 an episode
now get in there get this guy some juice
boxes also i love how the camera's set
up where you could just see
the before and after life you got the
pretty boy
yeah god you had it man he's a good kid
he was mixed up though i'll tell you
that he was mixed up he was insecure
um yeah you really gotta figure it was
this guy's not mixed up he's this guy's
now solid and secure you are a 311 song
you're all mixed up and then everything
from here on out it's dance all mixed up
don't know what to eat then i turn
around and i lose my feet
this is a musical podcast who knew i
knew 311 like that huh
they're real trash i um anyway one time
i didn't want to go into work obviously
because i was i was
not feeling well yes and it was like my
third couldn't
find your gas can it was my third or
fourth time that i that i had called out
so i was gonna be fired so i knew i had
to do something
really elaborate i mean i had to really
put on a show back again
i've done shows i've done shows so i'm
crashing real hard i [ __ ]
i'm supposed to do a lunch shift dude
just thinking about that stuff
god if i ever had to go back to waiting
tables i would just [ __ ] jump out a
window that's
from patreon.com i'll tell you if that
stimulus check don't come
you're going to catch him you're going
to catch him at a friday the minute is
screwing me in
trouble let's uh lucha can go [ __ ]
himself so i called him
you can eat my gooch i'm sorry i called
him up and i said i had strep throat
and he didn't really believe me and yeah
i'm doing the i'm sorry man
you can't oversell it oh my god well
this is what i did
all right i hung up i'm sorry man he's
like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
before you hurry up i bought it guys
drinks on me just put the coke over
there
take your pants off i have some
champagne coming in there
so i hung up and i immediately called
back his cell phone
by accident no i immediately called back
his cell phone and pretended like i was
called on my dad
like i had gotten mixed up in my
delirious state
and go hey dad i was like dad what's up
i had a call out of work man
i think i had to go to the hospital it's
like really burning that's [ __ ] next
level
wow and my boss is like hello is that
he's like he's like he's like henry
i'm like dad man it's like i'm really i
feel like i'm dying i can't really wipe
voices it
it hurts my body he's like it's it says
it's it's sam it's sam it's sam
it's not your dad he's like listen you
just rest up and you know we'll see you
in a couple of days take care of
yourself
[ __ ] wow and they bought it hall of
famer
hall of fame
i had to pick him up from the airport so
many times just being late to where i
i wouldn't miss work a lot but i'd be
late all the time it was like always a
new did he work at the airport
no but i had to be like he was out of
town i got a picture oh that was your
excuse nothing
like that yeah my mom had to go to work
i'm like where's the air are you flying
who's
flying that much hey segway sam you
wanna
stick to the script will you i remember
one time i was like
i was in a poconos one time
which my own cook um i remember one time
i was like four dad
14 13 i don't know young young and
where all my buddy justin's it was like
in the summer and i wore i always worked
really young and i wanted to
it was one of those things where like
something cool materialized like last
minute
i was like i'll go over to your house
hang out i gotta work at six
yeah so i'm like i'll hang out till five
and then i'll go to work or whatever
to bus tables at giuseppe's sucks and
something really cool starting with yeah
in the summer one of those like oh let's
do this yes oh
[ __ ] man nothing worse than being the
guy that i had to work with i know what
was going on
and no none of my friends had job you
know like
like i had like a i was busting table
like you had a responsibility other kids
were like camp counselors or whatever
and
uh i remember being like oh [ __ ] and
i'll call out so i just called up
giuseppe's
like the pizza place and like got the
person who takes the orders and i'm like
yeah yeah
you know it says kevin like i i can't
make it i don't have a ride you know
i'll see you later
thank you
you still running that party special
do i get the two-liter with that look um
so i hung up so then i hung up and i go
like you're so innocent and stupid you
go that's it
i'm in the party let's go and then my
mom then
calls justin's to house rings right and
she goes
i just got a call from just christina
giuseppe she's [ __ ] furious you can't
just
you know you can't just call out oh
christine
[ __ ] yourself based on no rise you're
leaning on a 14 year old kid i was
friends come on dinner service
it was like a [ __ ] it was it was a
jumping spot back i got a contract here
he uh the salad bar's down a man the
salad bar is down a man is that who you
were
salad bar no i was bus boy sometimes
salad depending if you either prepped to
set soups and salads or you were on
we got a sneezer you got to clean the
guard cause let me tell you something
the salad station in the kitchen's clean
living
yeah back there with the cooks when
you're young too nice and cooked
you make friends with the cook and they
give you they hook you up with the food
we used to pass off pulled meats just
like [ __ ] drug deals
yeah that was awesome great pulled meat
yeah like
like um you know short rib or something
you know just a handful of short ribs
you are
next level trash yes
you could have just said short ribs you
have your own dirtbag language
delaware ease i i was i was hanging with
my buddy one time
we were just drinking in the yard you
know like 2 p.m having like the best day
drinking time sure love it and he's like
i got to go to work he's like
[ __ ] i'm going to call off and he
calls and he's like they're like you
you have to show up if you don't show up
you are 100 fired
and he goes i'm so sorry i got hit by a
cab
so he hangs he hangs up the phone and
then
dives into a pile of gravel on the
sidewalk
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
he goes six times late i gotta bleed
oh my god you gotta sell it baby holy
[ __ ]
gotta give him this this the sizzle baby
it's funny you stressed about that it
didn't [ __ ] matter it doesn't [ __ ]
matter well that's what i'm saying so
then at
one point i didn't realize in my story
that like in my i was just like oh cool
we'll party
at [ __ ] justin's have a couple of
pops you know what i mean couple of
cocktails
couple of ladies coming over a couple
i didn't think that there's like nine
delivery drivers making deliveries so
they're like we'll just have one of the
nine people in cars
in your neighborhood that we're paying
to come pick you up like we'll get you a
ride if that's all that's stopping you
as a ride
we'll [ __ ] we'll have someone there
in 10 minutes to come pick you up so my
mom goes
i go you got a call and tell them i'm
sick mom like and she's like i'm not
[ __ ] wait hold on what was your
initial lie to christina i don't get a
ride
how do you [ __ ] i know man i was all
hopped up on the phone
14 year old underdeveloped brain i know
no foresight
i only got one sock yeah yeah i stopped
right yeah yeah yeah so you [ __ ] tell
them your mom just oh deed and you're
like i drafted it finger you got a
[ __ ] thick on your feet
i know but it went from so then i had a
call back i had it my mom ended up
taking me in but it went from i had to
be like
oh i found a ride dude it went from [ __ ]
i'm missing the party to i'm in the
[ __ ] party to [ __ ] i'm missing the
party again
it was talking about a roller coaster
talking about a rise and i know that i
know the piece knew what was up to you
she's like i ain't [ __ ] calling for
you you got to either go into work or
call him and tell him you quit
or something you know like you had this
was it a family friend that ran the
joint
nah it wasn't but [ __ ] that girl
christine this one time i spilled a
little bit and i went to get a rag and
by the time i came back she had slipped
on the water
she was a big girl and it wasn't like i
wasn't cleaning up i was like oh [ __ ]
that's what you get
for being a snitch dude and she [ __ ]
hated me dude she was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to me i'm like going back i'm like
i was like 13 and she was like 32. i'm
like who's mean to a 13 year old
fat kid trying to hire in a 13 year old
factory shout out to giuseppe
yeah he's fat so he's got the internal
organs of a 30 year old
he smokes too he's got a so
she [ __ ] hated the [ __ ] out of me and
then one time and then
years later i was like you know 18 or
whatever he stopped into a burger king
by the actual valley mall and she's
behind the counter
oh crap i was like yeah how long ago was
this
it was like [ __ ] ten years later or
eight years later so i'm like that i was
like a significant chunk of time later i
was an adult oh god
and i walked in and she was [ __ ] you
know working the burger king i'm like
you ever you ever been so broad yeah get
me
now get me my tent piece and hit the
bricks you always go i have a coupon
yeah and honey try not to slip in the
back huh
you fat [ __ ]
she hated the [ __ ] out of me there was a
[ __ ] whopper of a broad
i guess this is the home of the whopper
listen i don't know why but yeah when
you were a little kid and you worked at
places with adults there was always one
or two adults
that for no reason just hated you and
your friends that's how my manager was
it
uh i worked at a record store when i was
like 15 16.
and the man the the main manager that
hired me was such a pretentious dick but
all the other
employees like took me under their wing
and like you know were like really
cool yeah nice and fun and cool have you
ever fighter pilot
how do you get taken under your wing at
a record store no
we're just gonna roll these listen man
this is how the alphabet works yeah
let me show you the qr code
no you've ever seen liner notes before
have you ever have you ever been so bad
at a job that's like endearing to your
co-workers
no i've never been i've always hated
that guy that guy didn't just suck but
never got fired
i was i sucked at a job in the beginning
and then i like picked it up and was
fine but there was very much a grace
period how do you suck at working at a
record shop
no no i it was at a restaurant where i
just like you know like when you join
it's a huge menu and like you're kind of
like
sure blow it first
and then once you get in that groove
yeah you were just robotic like zip
zopping around
yeah that's when it rules when you have
no time to think you're just
you're just going in whoa and then the
parties after those nights are
pretty deep you're just chasing trading
pills yeah
yeah everybody's getting [ __ ] up being
told you can't have a shift drink
anymore
you drank already six months of [ __ ] i
pulled my ticket out once at the bar
giving people free champagne i think
they'll give you a big tip
seeing someone's name acting like your
cousins did you do that
oh yeah would you you'd be in business
for yourself a little bit oh my god this
one guy i was like
it was mcnulty's and ian's i was like
blackman i
i have a cousin uh where are you from i
have a cousin martina blackman he was
like south africa wait
you would do that you would lie to
custody yeah to try to like
be like hey you know the hope they would
give me like a tip
i didn't even know there was waiters
that taco bell that's crazy
nothing on that no he's still trying to
process what a [ __ ] dirtbag it was
oh my god are you you're james mahoney
oh my god that's crazy
of the mahoney's a [ __ ] newark wow oh
man you used to eat off people's plates
shut the [ __ ] up that's alicia
honor among thieves you know what i mean
jesus christ
you're pulling ponzi schemes at a
[ __ ] prefix yeah work smart not hard
dude yeah
um damn that's fine that was a fantastic
one i thought you meant like
you would like get the cooks because i
used to be able to you know to fire the
joint troughed off
you know i mean i'd be able to get a
couple of appetizers on the arm and haze
is on the house
you know what i mean and then you know
stuff i would do that but i would i
would not
i would just like hey
oh you're in new york for the first time
welcome here you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah trying to convince
somebody of their long-lost son
papa five dollars extra
i owe the other weight i guess it's a
leg up for college
i don't know oh dude one time i thought
me and the head chef had like i would
always
at the end of the night i'd get them
like a tequila or whatever and i thought
we
had like like we would joke and
everything like you know the back of the
house you
you call each other like racist names or
sure that's like the only thing you know
in spanish
the chef i thought we were like buds and
he was like
uh double tequila rocks and i was like
yeah i got your rocks right here
and he took me and shoved me up against
the walk and was like don't ever
disrespect me i was like
a joke i thought we were friends yeah
those those shorter
oh my god they're lunatics
those guys we had a teacher in high
school that was like that had a real
short fuse
but he was kind of a funny guy and some
kid walked in and was like
hey are you doc like it was freshman
year just met the guy
think he was in the wrong class he's
like you doc doc uh
doctor and he grabbed him he's like
you're making fun of my [ __ ] name
jacked him up against the wall
nobody set up pee put arrested jesus
christ school in the 30s was wild
stand by me no definitely [ __ ] you could
not get away with now
no way for sure oh my god some kid up in
the hallway
one one like priest took a a ruler and
like
or no no he took a stack of papers and
threw him off a kid's desk and he had to
go on sabbatical
really yeah they made him go away for
like two months uh
my cousin is a bit of a [ __ ] lunatic
he uh he was a teacher
at a couple of schools but he was a
private i think he was saying i think he
was teaching at saint joe's at the time
and he would tell the kids like if you
think you can
you've got a problem with me we can
solve it after school
jesus likes to buy the flagpole no he's
like he's like dude get your regression
like
you think you can do it let's go need to
go into like the wrestling room or
whatever
and they would just like [ __ ] wrestle
it out like jesus christ i don't think
he's employed by them anymore oh my god
one time i saw the most badass thing but
i'm like that's good dude if
i was in high school the teacher was
like you got a [ __ ] problem let's go
[ __ ] dude they're getting out your
aggression
at this hood school i was uh student
teaching at in the hallway this kid was
like
mouthing off to a teacher and the
teacher did not back down and he was
like
i'll [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] out of you
the teacher goes you know why you're not
going to do it because you don't have
the [ __ ] heart and the kid just stood
there and i was like
i'm sorry and i was like damn that's
damn that's great yes
just right in his face didn't flinch
meanwhile you're handing the kid your
wallet
wild inspector okay
the siphons in the backseat
[ __ ] it up real quick yeah yeah um
all right this one is from that's great
this one is from let's see this is brian
rizzi
uh have you ever opened uh a new bank
account or credit card anything you know
just to get the free promotional gift or
item oh my god
no neither have i
i told the story before i think is i had
to do uh
i worked at macy's in order to get my my
credit in order to get my store discount
i had to open up a credit card and put
it on their credit card
right and i ran that i mean i just paid
that off a couple of months ago that was
from like 2002.
goddard flyest looking kid on street
rave yeah street radio dude
doctors all day yeah well i wasn't doing
i was in college i was an idiot i wasn't
doing laundry i would just put it on the
[ __ ] car and i'd buy
socks and you know oh meanwhile i was
making eight dollars an hour and i was
spending more than i think you'd be rich
of course there's nothing better than
that going out and getting something to
wear that night that's
real garbage but it feels real good as
well when it gets a little chilly you go
out and get a hat
just buy something [ __ ] feels nice
that's how trash you are do you ever buy
something is that why luggage stores and
stuff exists at the airport
yeah okay you [ __ ] impulse buy
[ __ ] get you coming oh dude i'll buy
anything at an airport
oh my god dude
i need a cup of coffee i'm walking out
with 10 waters a newspaper and a book
and a hudson news i'm saying
this is a dean coote story and
everything
um i remember uh i opened up a
i one day i went to the bank to do the
penny arcade
remember td bank had sally or whatever
that [ __ ] yes penny
penny yeah yeah it was dimey quarterly
that's very exciting penny no not penny
um anyway uh they at some at a certain
point they put the kibosh
on open to the public that you had to
open in a
you had to have an account to do it and
i rolled in there with this [ __ ]
there was no way i was either going to
throw them out
or [ __ ] i was getting my money there
was no way i was carrying these penny i
think i was living at your place
there's no way i was like yeah there's
no in philly yeah there's no way i was
humping this this [ __ ] bag of change
back to my [ __ ] apartment
cargo pants are changing yeah you like
kramer paying for the calzone so i
opened an account just so i could use
the penny arcade
next question yeah this guy is trash
what i that's
the answer they're just ridiculous i
answered the direct question
i thought it was an amusing story so i
opened up the account and closed it 12
months later
yeah apr no money down
so you don't have to write your return
address on the letter i rolled that over
into an ira
living comfortably now thank you thank
you 20 31 i'll have 17
10. this one is [ __ ] fantastic i saw
this came in last night or two nights
ago this is from chad bell he says this
is from his 16 year old son
have you ever clapped at the end of the
movie or after your flight landed
yes and yes trashed yes you're clapping
at the end
i'm about to start clapping at 5 pm for
the nurses again
at seven exactly yeah well daylight
saving time
dude if you're clapping at the end of
your flight from like you know virginia
to florida or something you are training
from here to pittsburgh i love it i love
landing is my favorite part
[ __ ] coming into the adrenaline just
a little tickle in your belly
you two [ __ ] icing me out here what
do you mean well
my favorite
yeah you should have lost confidence
before too
my favorite part is where they give out
to your name i like the tsa because
sometimes they touch you
i definitely roll around with the
cookies
hey toast make it with the pretzels
let's get them if it's a real good movie
or a little bit of a dicey landing yeah
there's a sense of relief no who are you
[ __ ] john what are you elon musk
[ __ ]
no not everybody first of all not
everybody's clapping so it's not a thing
you're supposed to what do you think
at the end of a
messing bangs hank and sarah i figured
my girlfriend there were a hole in her
jeans
clapping for that it was like vanqvan
and ghostbusters
this guy's off the wall okay whoa
call me vans i'm off the wall ian
finance unleashed
wow this is uh this is a great i picked
this one out just for [ __ ] ian um
do you want to go back to my td bank
story let me know how you land yeah
let's close that account
hey foley that story about the plane
let's land it okay
let's take a leonard skinner on that
plane that's the idea this is called
comedy i talk about not giving you
anything
you're the [ __ ] black hole over here
i hate you i like flying
it's okay for everybody united airlines
she's fine
i actually joined a reward program one
time because i was bored on a plate
and my favorite parts landed and we
weren't landing so i figured i got to
kill shrimp
um this is from mike the this is another
uh
history aina's shout out mike the fuzzy
non-muzzy sandra dj um
do you keep your cat food on the counter
for your cat i forgot you have a cat too
yeah no i keep it in the automatic
feeder
you keep it on the counter the cans are
stored in the fridge with a with a
little top on it
and then when i got a feeder i go get
her dish i clean out the dish
i put the cat food in the dish where's
the dish
that's i think that's what he's asking
it's set up on the floor next to a water
dish like
you know on a little little kind of
little carpet
this guy's got the cat eating off the
counter i don't know i mean it's it's
apparently ugh i used to feed i used to
feed my cat
oh god well i used to feed
i i had a dog and a cat and i used to he
used to eat the dog food so i was like
all right i'm just going to feed them
dog food so they would like eat all the
same bowl whatever
and i had to go to way to [ __ ] detox
and i had my my neighbor
watch my cat and at the same time i
would make myself tuna and avocado
sandwiches every day
so i'm gone this guy she's like a car
i'm bracing
i'm gone and i come back and the cat
is just screaming at the cabinet next to
the dishes
what the [ __ ] he's she fed him the tuna
every day
he's spoiled and i'm like you dumb [ __ ]
it's dog food not
tuna and she goes how could a human eat
that much
tuna it was just a
cabinet full of tuna and the cat's got
ptsd
because he's getting spoiled for a week
because i can't [ __ ] handle my
alcohol what kind of life are you living
where you're my kid
you gotta go to detox you're eating
strictly tuna and avocado sandwiches
and your cat's eating dog food what the
[ __ ]
dude and i'm living i'm living next to a
public pool like
i cut the barbed wire out so i could hop
in and i can go for a swim
dude this guy's bonkers living off river
road in delaware baby in an old
farmhouse
high protein no good for you shout out
to warren he used to knock money off my
rent because i was a groundskeeper
it was a wild time in delaware boys hot
time in delaware
who eats that much too yeah she was like
that's inhuman
you know you're in a bad situation when
your cat's eating dog food
that's like a telltale sign you gotta go
to send that thing to therapy
so both of you should be at rehab so
i'm eating tuna fish and he's eating dog
food
can we share a room please we're writing
a treatment together
that's literally insane it's an
alcoholic freaky friday
we both me out at the same time and
i'm eating cat food and cheesy and dog
food i don't know what's happening now
she's drinking
it's crazy i'm looking at his ass i
don't know what she's gotta go to work
for me
i'm like oh my god i got a corkscrew
penis who knows what's happening
i'm living in a cardboard box for all
the wrong reasons
how's that cat doing uh he's good he's
all right
he's on his diet now you know
wait as he lives with my mom is better
off does he really yeah it's still alive
yeah turns out he's an outdoor cat
i just want to get the [ __ ] away from
you
oh god that one my size
i i have one that i think i know the
answer to
this is from john torres and the
question is
uh have you ever had a dedicated spot
for cigarette shorts where you like keep
ex
like a little happy dirty
that's dirty no and people who put them
back in the package
no i've done that but no
it's it's like [ __ ] you smoke under
the butt also
also for the little chick you go all the
way to the butt
and a guy all for the listeners i don't
like eating guys
okay great moving on
fully w tell me more about just checking
out
check-ins
so i go in there td make it up
i go in there i got all my stuff with me
there's no way of carrying this stuff
back to the apartment
and i go to use it that says enter your
[ __ ] checking account number
i don't have a chance to go back so i go
over i wait
all right okay all right hey here we are
thanks for tuning in to are you garbage
folks
oh my god
and they made me put the money in these
they made me put the money in the
account oh my god and i had to wait like
two weeks to get a card in the mail
um wait for the no that's gross to
save the bots is [ __ ] come on it's
super gross
but also uh is the king
oh he used to be i don't know if he
still is he was the king of bum he'd
come up to
me and let me get his cigarette you'd
give it to him and he would put it in
his pocket
and he'd open up a pack with like four
sigs in it put your sig
in there and then walk away did i do
that a lot dude did i
do that replenishing your marlboro like
soft pack by the way ian's a soft soft
pack fella
that's right yep soft pack pop it out
holy [ __ ] yep oh that was insane
five different cigarettes in there yeah
it's like tri-colored tortellini in
there you don't know what you're gonna
get
fun times what time are we at there
t-bone
uh okay great let's do a couple more
yeah
just too much fun oh this is one of my
favorite episodes i think ever
yes oh man those [ __ ] rules i've been
crying it's so funny okay uh
let me i gotta regain my [ __ ]
consciousness here um have you or a
family ever been thrown out of a little
league sporting event for arguing with
the
ref or another family member or anything
i believe you've already asked that oh
did we
okay sorry no i haven't not that we
can't do it sure
but i don't remember asking him i mean
maybe yeah um that was from andrew
miller for sure
i remember we got in a fight we got a
hockey fight with kids with the team
like the kids
i got kicked out of playing roller
hockey
with a cigarette was in like sixth grade
i was angry
were you at like was it a league or was
it like a yeah it was like a league yeah
and i i cross-checked a kid knocks him
on the ground i was kicked out
kicked out damn that was kick that was
it where you're on roller skates
started smoking i was on foot i didn't
ever no no
that was the real trashy on a bike
i had skates do you guys ever play foot
hockey in the street
uh yeah we were mainly always on
rollerblades but there would be some
times where you would
that was tough because then you had to
get everybody together and not everybody
had rollerblades yeah who could have we
were a big hockey that was rich kid [ __ ]
yeah we were a big hockey i mean they
were like 40 bucks
yeah no no the cheap ones where the
wheel wore down you're going on a
[ __ ] little diamond skating history
you had to [ __ ] rotate the wheels
i had roller skates for a little while
they were metal
brutal metal were they just under
did you like skate in the or you would
wear them to like skating parties i just
kept rolling
did you ever have a roller skating party
oh yeah like you for your birthday or
anything
[ __ ] proper young's regency shout out
to young's regency
and bluebell pa they did it right they
had a little [ __ ] disco dance floor
and [ __ ] slushies and let me tell you
something some of the best goddamn pizza
pizza the roller skating palace was i
don't know dude
i don't know what they put in that [ __ ]
it was crispy and cheese i think they
used cheddar cheese too
it was real trashy we used to go ours
used to be remember
we have a story there when we were at
the mine used to be and still is i think
used to be right next to the comedy
cabaret on the boulevard the roller
skating palace is where all my
parties were yeah and that lady showed
us her titties out front
remember yes oh my god i remember that
and then we went to steve's princess
steaks
wait you guys knew each other when you
were little kids no we were
doing comedy yeah at the comedy cabaret
which is right next to the roller
skating palace and the woman yeah
that's like ramadan whose birthday was
it
this guy's out to lunch i mean what do
you mean we were doing a show at the
comedy cabaret
uh yeah we're not gonna woman showed us
her titties outside the comedy cabaret
which was next to the roller skating
place yeah which you've never been to
no nice checks out all right
next question keep keep up fatty right
let's open this guy a roth ira
um this is from this is uh this is from
will campbell have you ever
uh bought weed off a relative or one of
your friends relatives
i sold weed to a relative to your proper
relative
yeah second coat was it a holiday it was
around christmas
did they did you know you were related
at the time yeah
we went to like a christmas dinner and
we like got along real well and we're
like let's go [ __ ] drink and we went
out and drank
went to this place galucios doesn't
sound
where i used to go and get hammered and
[ __ ] wear my work clothes sleep in my
car and just go to work the next morning
yes
and uh so we went there and then we went
back to his place and he started getting
like real [ __ ] weird when he was high
and i just left without saying goodbye
to him
is he at christmas man he was like a
cousin i don't like see often you know
and i was like i gotta get out of here
yeah have you ever done
drugs with somebody and then like either
halfway through it or at the end of it
they were like
uh you know can you send me something
can you give me some money for this
where it was under the impression that
it was like no but when i first started
smoking weed i hit a friend up and was
like hey man you want to smoke and he's
like hell yeah come on over i was like
all right so i showed up and he's like
where's the weed i was like
no you have the weed he was like what
the [ __ ]
hey would you come over here i didn't
know i was like yeah let's smoke your
weed
let's do your drugs give me 10 bucks
please get me a sandwich
yeah i never i don't think i've ever
bought or sold weed
or yeah not that i can recall you ever
smoked that [ __ ]
yeah it got real high right or one time
you ever done a little bit of
no no no no um have you
ever you've never done coke no pot why
your eyes tell differently
yeah they're [ __ ] bugging out
his eyes his eyes have been in rehab
four times
your eyes are catchy i'm back baby
hey your eyes are eating tuna pal
kippy's got the feds or listening face
you want to see helicopters i got big
eyes
what about all right that's it everybody
thanks for tuning in
what about molly you ever do molly no
ecstasy no all my
i didn't i was alert i found out yeah i
found out at the young age i was
allergic to vicodin and percocet
and then from then allergic man i always
break out in handcuffs
they got really popular all my friends
were doing those like crazy like i mean
painkillers were like i mean i saw
friends popular that's a really good way
to
that's right they were in
they were hot in [ __ ] 2002 to 2005.
perk tens the school buses
buddy they were something else yeah so
remember the oxy you didn't have to suck
the coating off
to get high well all my friends at some
point oxy and stuff and i just never i
was like
yeah i just didn't have that i don't
want to say like gateway into it but it
was like
weed made me paranoid i love party and i
would have done i found out
my [ __ ] throat swelled up on [ __ ]
painkillers
so i'm like all right well that's what
everybody's doing i don't like weed so i
just drank a lot
a lot all right well this has been
brought to you by td bank
talk about leaving your hands cool bozo
steal your laptop and leave whatever man
let's go hang out with bingo for a
little while these guys all use that at
the ground round
dude the fact you would bring your own
magician to the ground imagine going
into like a [ __ ] tgi fridays and
bringing your own entertainment that's
crazy
hey he's gonna play the guitar for a
couple of minutes hey we promised bingo
a meal is that
uh the clown show is a writer what
is it smoking or non-smoking session
he's eating in the kitchen
buddy thank you so much for sitting in
with us what a [ __ ] great this is
awesome family episode
patreon little company
shout out to t-bone t-bone
uh ian anything you want the folks out
there to know obviously i'll say this if
you haven't seen ian's episode it's
episode number one
numero uno make sure you check it out it
stinks
you can see the progression of the
podcast
how bad it sucked to how awesome it is
now
this is the guy [ __ ] talk about a
tune-up game
he was it ladies and gentlemen this guy
came in cold and left soft
he's not my td bank story go
check out episode number one i tell that
i tell that drinking story twice
thank you everybody for all the
questions ian anything you want anybody
to the gang to know out there anything
coming up anything
go right down the barrel baby uh i got a
lot of sketches coming out from my
instagram
i animal 69. ianfidance.com
and uh yeah that's about it for now very
nice buddy we love you very much thank
you so much and thank you for coming in
we've been friends since [ __ ] jump
street off
the streets of philly kippy what do you
got the folks out there to know uh just
as always make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube guys go to
patreon.com you can sign up when you
sign up there's a comment thread you can
leave your question we'll get to it
obviously
we have still a lot to get to but we
will get to all of the questions that
you guys asked the garbage army is
growing
uh yeah we love it we appreciate all
this [ __ ] support the numbers are
through the [ __ ] roof and they allow
us to do this
which we really [ __ ] appreciate so uh
check out the patreon also
podcastmarch.com
get yourself a t get involved grab a
hoodie grab a t
at kevin ryan comedy on all social media
thank you so much
at age four i have a garbagio shirt i
wore it on new york one
oh that's right yeah he also paid retail
for it
at holi on ice at foleygrams on
instagram
thank you and that was that was so sweet
supporting the pod i think that was him
asking for the money back to be honest
we got to meet give me a check what do
you what large what are you
yeah we got we got a clean living for
you guys yeah there you go two for one
take a walk
go get your girls follow
i can't process that